each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay hello everyone thanks for coming to
the immediately post lunch and talk and
it is my immense pleasure to introduce
Armando solar Lizama who is a professor
at MIT so I Rando is one of the world's
leading experts on program synthesis and
he is leading a group computer-aided
programming at MIT and before that he
obtained his PhD from Berkeley and he
worked on a new program synthesis
technique called sketching which
actually revived interest in program
synthesis and several people have since
then he know started working on this
topic again Amy including so that was a
very inspiring piece of work and 02 I
remember now to tell you more about the
exciting things that he has been doing
at MIT since then thank you thank you
very much so for today's talk I decided
to focus on some of the new stuff that
we've been working on over the last
couple of months in in my group most in
fact all of the work that you'll see
here is it still unpublished it's at the
stage right now where it's starting to
produce results so it's a very it's a
very exciting stage it's at the stage
where if you give me a hard question
that I can't answer it's going to make
the future paper all that much better so
please do ask lots and lots of questions
so my my group the group that I've just
started at MIT for now a little over a
year it's called the computer-aided
programming group and as the name
suggests a lot of our inspiration comes
from this this field and this idea of
computer-aided design computer-aided
engineering so computer-aided design
computer-aided engineering has been
around at least since the 1960s it was
one of the it was one of those
applications of computers that had a
very dramatic impact in the way people
do engineering and the way people design
things all the way from airplanes and
cars to two buildings
and it's kind of interesting to look at
the way this field has evolved and some
of the parallels with the way
programming languages have evolved so if
you look at some of the papers in this
area from starting reading in the 1960s
and really all the way to the 1980s a
lot of the issues that people worried
about in this field we're very much the
same kind of issues that people in
programming languages have been worrying
about for a while things like how do you
organize your design so that it's easier
to understand and easier to communicate
how do you manage this very large
designs for something like an airplane
or a building how do you modularize it
so that you can design different pieces
independently and put them together how
do you do reusability so that if you're
dealing with a part where you have to
make lots of copies of it with small
differences you can actually
parameterize this part so that you have
this parameterised part where you can
create lots of instances of it for
different contexts and different
situations how do you compile these
designs and in this case what people
mean what we mean by compiling a design
well something like taking your designs
that you've made in the computer and
building actual mechanical parts out of
them you saying things like numerically
controlled machines or how did you
generate drawings so that the builders
in the field and the the welders in the
plant can actually use these drawings to
to generate this product and even at
this point people are already starting
to worry about very low level checks
things like checking compatibility
between different parts but what you
could almost think about this interface
checking making sure that if you design
one part and you design another part
when you put them together they're
actually going to match so a lot of
these a lot of these things are very
much the kind of things that people have
been worrying about in programming
languages for a very long time how do
you create modular designs how do you
organize your designs a lot of the
literature at the time also talked about
things like version control how do you
make sure that how do you keep different
version of the same design organized now
some interesting things started
happening around the 1990s so for a very
long time people had already been
looking at analyzing this designs from
the point of view of doing say finite
element analysis or doing simulations
but one of the really interesting things
that started happening in the 90s is
that people started really looking for
push button design validation at the
level of this computer aided side tools
they wanted to be able to press a button
and see how this particular piece that
they designed was going to dissipate
heat for example or how this particular
piece that they designed was going to
withstand vibrations and so there was a
big movement for taking a lot of these
technology that have been developed for
numerical simulation actually
incorporating it as part of these
computer-aided design tools so you could
say that today something very similar is
happening in the world of software for a
lot of these technology that we have
been developing for a very long time for
verifying programs for checking them for
validating them it's actually moving
into the mainstream it's moving into a
position where people in the field can
actually push a button and check their
programs check for bugs but in the 2000s
something really interesting happen
which is in this field ones that you
have all of these decision procedures in
place once you have the capability of
simulating your designs and of analyzing
people actually started playing with
design synthesis and what people refer
to as design optimization which
essentially in this setting means that
you actually create a design and give it
to the system and tell it this is not
just a sign this actually entire space
of possible designs for the wing of your
airplane or for the airfoil in your race
car or even for the buttresses in a
building and you actually give it to the
computer and have the computer go and by
relying on this decision procedures that
they have developed over the years get
the system to actually help you with the
design it's it's interesting to think at
for example race cars if you look at how
the airfoils in race cars look used to
like they were very geometric it's the
kind of things you can design with a
ruler and a pencil a lot of straight
lines very simple curves this is the
kind of thing that people would design
by hand and then simply vial the date
through the simulator compare that with
the kind of air foils that you see today
which are actually designed through this
kind of parameter optimization where you
have very complex shapes very complex
curves where you actually give it to the
system and tell the system I want an
airfoil that maximizes downward force
while minimizing drag this is the kind
of thing that we would really like to be
able to do with programs we would really
like to be able to take some of the
burden of designing this very complex
systems and leave it up to the machine
to do it now one of the interesting
things about this metaphor relating
computer-aided design and programming is
that in the computer aided design world
from the very beginning from the very
early days people have been aware that
these are not automated decide tools
this tools are not called computerized
it signed they are purposely called
computer-aided design and what does that
mean it means that we're not leaving the
designed to the tools rather what we're
looking for is a synergy between the
Machine and the humans because we really
after is being able to exploit the
knowledge and the insights that
programmers have and combine them with
the power of machines for doing very
thorough design space exploration for
doing very detailed analysis of the
low-level aspects of the design and
really combine them together in a way
that is to the benefit of both this
doesn't mean for example simply using
the human as an Oracle so that when the
machine gets stuck the human has to go
in and fix the mess that the machine
made it really means designing from the
very beginning looking at this problems
from the point of view of what is it
that the human nose and what is it that
the Machine knows what is it that the
machine is good at and being able to
combine the capabilities of the human
with the capabilities of the machine to
actually make four systems
that make programming easier and simpler
that allow better productivity from the
side of the programmers that allow fewer
bugs and they're ultimately allow our
the dream goal is to allow for the signs
that programmers by themselves could
have not achieved so this is the goal
and in particular what we want to do as
part of the work of my group is we want
to go beyond validation the next
frontier beyond validation is going to
be to use the capabilities that we have
to actually help the programmer come up
with these designs and come up with this
programs in the first place so today I'm
going to talk about three projects that
that we recently started at at MIT as I
said all three of these projects that
are relatively early stage but I'm going
to talk about what are the key ideas and
what are the main results that we have
so far but all these three projects are
looking at dealing with three very
important problems the first one has to
do with implementing complex algorithms
if you talk to a lot of people today
they will tell you well nowadays people
don't really write complicated
algorithms they don't really write
complicated data structures it turns out
a lot of people don't but there are a
lot of people who do ultimately somebody
has to write the runtime for the CLR
somebody has to write the libraries on
which net or Java subsistent yes even
though modern programming languages have
given us this tremendous abilities to
reuse this complicated algorithms and
this complicated data structures so that
yes most people in the field don't have
to worry about them but ultimately
somebody has to sit down and write them
and for the people who actually have to
sit down and write them the tools that
they have at their disposal today are
actually not the different from the
tools that people had their disposal in
the 1970s except maybe for the ability
nowadays to at least validate their
designs so we're going to talk about
some technologies that could make that
process simpler we're also going to talk
about another problem that a lot of
programmers do face on a day-to-day
basis and it is the problem of dealing
with this really large code bases
with programs that are so large that not
single that not a single person
understands the whole thing but so we
want the machine to help us reason about
this programs to help us understand
what's going on with this programs and
help us with a problem of going and
adding functionality to this program so
building functionality on top of these
very complicated frameworks this is a
very important problem and very
difficult to one because these programs
are at the scale we're not only humans
have a very hard time understanding them
but even our current analysis
capabilities also have very hard time
understanding them and finally we're
going to talk about in this issue of
unpredictable environments one of the
things that makes programming in card is
the fact that when you write a program
particularly when you write a program
that is going to have to interact with
the world in some fun you have to think
beyond the common case you have to
really think about all the different
puzzles in areas that might arise where
the the main algorithm that is running
your program might have to do something
a little bit different might have to use
slightly different code might require
some slightly different line of
reasoning to deal with each one of these
different corner cases and a lot of
times this corner crazy server is not
necessarily out of the specification but
out of some properties of the
programming tools so let's so to deal
with this complicated algorithms I'm
going to talk about this idea of
storyboard programming on the key idea
is we want to turn the programmers
graphical insights into code so this is
work with the student rishabh sing we're
also going to talk about this project
called matchmaker which a is RIA case
study in data-driven synthesis and then
using large amounts of data about the
execution of the program to actually
help the programmer come up with pieces
of code that are needed in order to
fulfill a particular programming task
and finally I'm going to talk about this
project with the jinyang dealing with
specification based hardening which is
again which where the idea is to use
symbolic reasoning to make
more robust to allow programmers to cope
with some of these unexpected situations
so any questions up to this point
alright so let's start with this idea of
storyboard programming so it is really a
metaphor a lot of animated films today
actually start their life as a story
work one of the storyboard well the
storyboard what it is is it's a sequence
of frames that describes the action in
the movie it essentially describes the
sequence of events that are going to
happen as the movie progresses and it's
a great mechanism for communicating the
insight in this case of the creative
writers and an artist communicating
their insight to this very rigid and
very rule-bound structure which in this
case happens to be not a machine but
studio executives so it's a mechanism
for communicating this creative insight
to the studio executives and what it is
again it's the sequence of frames the
sequence that describes the action of
the movie so now the question is why
can't we do the same thing to
communicate our insights and our
intentions to the computer so we've come
up with this idea of storyboards
programming and it's particularly geared
to programs like data structure
manipulations where programmers really
start with this very high level this
very graphical intuition of how the
program is to proceed and then what they
have to do is they have to take this
very high level graphical intuition
about how their data structures are
going to evolve and convert it into a
sequence of pointer updates converted
into a sequence of destructive updates
into this invisible heap that is
completely conceptual like what you end
up with is this inscrutable massive code
that if you want to have any chance of
understanding it you really have to
reverse engineer you have to reconstruct
from this sequence of pointer updates
this graphical intuition that tells you
this is what's actually going on in your
data structure so what we want is we
want to allow programmers to convey
their insight in the form of a
storyboard and what is this storyboard
the storyboard
it is essentially a cartoon version of
this data structure transformation in
this case for example you can see that
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to insert an element into a linked list
so we start with a linked list where a
happens to be less than X and B happens
to be greater than X and then we finish
with the same data structure where now X
is sitting there right in the middle now
in addition to this we want to provide
the system with some structure some
structure that tells the system the kind
of solutions that we're looking for in
this case this you can call this a
sketch or a scaffold it's really
providing the control flow structure of
the solution that you expect but the key
insights really come from here from the
storyboard which is providing which is
get telling you a story it's telling you
about how this data structure is going
to evolve in the process of doing this
data structure transformation this
storyboard is actually composed of
different scenarios each one of these
difference in areas corresponds to
different situations different cases
that the input is going to have to deal
with in this case in addition to the
common case where the data structure
where you're inserting into the middle
of the data structure you have to worry
about the case where you're inserting at
the end where you're inserting at the
beginning for you're inserting into this
empty data structure so the storyboard
is essentially providing the scenarios
yes daughter box is something special
yes this is an excellent question so one
of the things that you see here is one
way to think about this is this
essentially an input output pair this is
essentially an example that says when
you get a lift like this you want to
produce a list like this but it's more
than an input output pair because we're
using some abstraction here what we're
really telling the system is you're
going to get this list and there is this
part of the list that it's just some
series of notes that you don't
particularly care about and then there
is the interesting part the part where
you're actually going to be modifying
and starting the thing and then there's
again this boring part that just
contains a lot a lot of notes and when
you're done the front part is going to
be the same and the back part is going
to be the same and what's the change is
going to happen here in the middle where
this is where the important stuff
happens inserting in a sorted list yes
but you should have some kind of a
predicate saying that exists between a
and B right yes that's absolutely right
so why is that not in the picture
because I forgot so yes you're
absolutely right so you also need a
predicate here that says the fact that
all the elements in front are less than
a and that a is less than X that X is
less than B and the b is less than all
the elements in back so this is the
predicate and this is exactly the
predicate that you need and so the idea
is this predicate is really part of the
storyboard is part of the description of
what's going on in this execution and
from that the system actually
synthesized is a correct implementation
of the list insertion and implementation
that realises that what it has to do is
iterate over this front part until it
gets to the interesting stuff and when
it gets to the interesting stuff it has
to go and insert into the interesting
stuff by doing some pointer
manipulations and that it has to worry
about different cases like the case
where the head is equal to no or the
case where privacy equal to null in
which case you are inserting at the
beginning of the list so
this is the information that that you
want to provide to the synthesizer so
now the question is what do you need in
order to actually make this real so the
first thing and really the most
important thing is you need to give
semantic meaning to the storyboard you
need to be able to go from this very
abstract graphical description to
something that the system actually can
manipulate some things the system can
actually reason formally about so that
it can actually tell whether what it's
producing actually conforms to the
storyboard that you provided so the
storyboard is in the storyboard as I
said before you can think of it as a set
of input-output pairs but it's a little
bit more than that the fact that you
have this abstract nodes means that the
single improv would pair but it's really
representing it's an infinite family of
input-output pairs it's describing the
behavior of this program on an infinite
set of input-output pairs so this on the
one hand helps you constraint the set of
solutions that you want to consider but
it also gives you something very
important it tells the system what to
focus on what do we want to do is we
want to take advantage of this
abstraction the user is providing the
fact that the user is telling you what's
happening here is not really that
relevant this is where the interesting
stuff is happening that's what you
really need to reason about in order to
reason about this data structure
manipulation so you want to treat the
storyboard as a specification but you
also want to treat it as a source of an
abstraction as something that tells you
what's important what you need to reset
about in order to get your algorithm
right so then of course you need to
actually be able to use this insight
presenting the storyboard to make the
synthesis happen and I'm going to talk a
little bit about how do we deal with
issues of expressiveness and scalability
so to see how we do this let's start by
thinking a little bit of that by looking
a little bit more detail at the
information that we need to be able to
extract out of these storyboards so the
first thing we're going to extract out
of a storyboard is an environment so the
first thing that you have in an
environment is a sequence of variables
some of these
it's actually show up in the storyboard
some of them don't show up in the
storyboard but instead they come from
the scaffold the fact that you have this
current and this previous pointer so the
environment the environment describes
those those variables that are going to
be necessary to reason about this data
structure manipulation the idea is that
this is provided by the creative
designer this is extracted from the
storyboard right right now we're
actually at the stage of writing these
by hand but I'm going to try to convince
you that this offices is a graph text
representation of what you see in this
picture with a couple of extra things so
first you have the variables and again
the variables just come from the
scaffolding then you have a collection
of concrete nodes those come directly
from the storyboard the story would
tells you that in order to reason about
this you really only have to reason
about this concrete nodes a X and B and
you really don't really need to reason
about any additional concrete notes
there what you have are this abstract
notes front and back so the system is
also going to have to reason about this
abstract notes front and back and here
you also need to tell the system a
little bit about this abstract notes and
relationships between them in this case
the fact that fronted up next in other
words any abstract note coming from any
concrete note coming from front its next
pointer can either point to front or it
can point to a and in the case of back
the fact that back next can either point
to back or it can point to know and
finally you have this invariant that
says that the talk describes the
relationship between the nodes in your
storyboard the fact that the front two
node has to be less than a and the day
has to be less than X X has to be less
than B this is something that the
user has to provide separately it's it's
an invariant about the data structure
that you're trying to synthesize so in
addition to the environment you have
this scenario it's actually composed of
two frames the first frame says this is
how things look like before i start the
execution of the program and this is how
things look like at the end of the
program and this is just a text
description of this picture all it's
saying is its describing the connections
that you see graphically in this picture
so now the key is that from this
scenario from the environment what we're
actually going to do is we're going to
derive an abstraction and this in in our
case yes yes somewhere in this desert
innocent I information that your
reasoning about not terminated
right otherwise you cannot go from this
picture to what is so that is this has
to be I mean that has to be able to
infer mation that's provided by creative
design in this case it's actually not
the case so you can actually think of
these the the only case where that
becomes relevant is here from the point
of view of this Perkins all the
information that we have here is the
fact that this corresponds to some set
of notes and that if you take one of
those nodes and you do dot next on it
either it's going to take you to another
node in here or it's going to take you
to a what you're writing
right so the picture has the picture has
in addition to this information it also
has this information right here picture
not show an arrow from to be
that's a good question so this is
actually something that is part of our
and there's actually something that's
part of our description of the scene the
fact that this is really how the list
looks like at least the list that I care
about the data structure is that I care
about this is how they look like and
from front there are links to a but
there are no links to be and I don't
want also to be links to X or links
directly to back so I really only care
about lists that look exactly like this
in the beginning and at the end I want
them to look exactly like this yes so
does the picture also did you say that
the friend zone is going to live in
exactly the same as a friend zone below
like what about the links between the
different modes in the front set can be
change or the not superstition this is a
very important question so right now the
convention that we're using is that this
abstract notes cannot change and this is
a very strong restriction I'll talk a
little bit more in a few slides about
how that how we can actually deal with
that restriction yes sort of
yes we shaped grass and there's all
sorts of hygiene conditions and all
sorts of extra things you know picture
maybe a thousand words but you know a
few symbols are worth a thousand
pictures right so so to you more
technically do you do you do you give us
recite to use their sort of emotions of
I Jean conditions and I mean are you
using something like they're in ocean
currents or house there so you could you
could think of this as a cartoon version
of shape analysis some of the important
things that we don't have here and that
we're trying to get away without are the
kind of elaborate predicates that you
see sometimes in shape analysis things
like reach ability predicate a lie for
example you can't have I mean some are
just obvious to programmers but not to a
computer system like next can only point
to one thing the pointer can only will
point the one thing in a graph you can
make it point to two things but we know
that the next field can only
alright so those things are implicitly
encoded here oh those yes there's others
that you know that there's no dangling
though there's no garbage all the sort
of things you get when you really want
to precisely describe the picture so I
got absolutely right so essentially
there is a set of background there's a
set of background conditions here in
terms of yes why are you trying to get
away from the reachability predicate
expose you said that explicitly right
you don't want to use a meat you're
gonna be pretty good right now what are
the things that we're trying to see is
how far we can push this with very
simple with very simple predicates that
you can get out of the picture with very
minimal extra annotation so it's
probably you will probably need them for
for certain complicated things but we're
trying to see how far we can push it
with just a very simple interpretation
of this graph just based on very simple
predicates and very simple predicate
abstraction
so
it's ugly it's big deal if that a friend
and that can change it because you can
always come and explore opportunity
having front and back not have to change
its not conceptually it's not in
practice it if front and back and don't
have to change it makes the algorithm a
little bit simpler in general if
abstract nodes don't have to don't have
to change it it makes certain aspects of
the encoding simpler seeing is it going
further you want that was on campus
tours change you can actually been to
change getting ahead of me but that is
that is exactly that is exactly right
trying to understand is it true that
your fear that what you right at the
bottom this assertion actually means
something specifically with the pointer
structure as a coat when I first read
this as what you're talking about
sorting the lace basins beam at your
peers but you're actually talking about
point2 structure here so this a very
good point this is not about the pointer
structure this is just a statement about
the value stored in node a versus the
value of the nodes that belong to the
cept front versus the value of the nodes
that belong to the set back we're
loading you know the pointer values and
the data value store here right yes so
that is solely for the purpose of
presentation this should actually be you
know front vowel and a dot Val except
then it gets to understand
you know the picture you know that the
arrows goes that way that you know the
picture the sequence of hours in the
picture are very specific is the key the
key is what you're trying to do is you
want to get this environment from the
picture not the other way around so from
the picture you want to get the fact
that you have a certain set of variables
you want to get the fact that you have a
certain set of concrete nodes a certain
set of abstract nodes the fact that you
have certain relationships between the
pointers for this nodes and the fact
that you have certain relationships
between the values of those nodes the
pointer structure is really coming into
play here in the description of the
scenario where you're stating very
explicitly the fact that X points to
some node in front sorry the fact the
CAD points to some note in front the
fact that aid of next points exactly to
be yes I don't see anything on the left
that tells me that crunchy 22 a
but the thing is that he's not saying
that the left is has just as much
information as a picture right he wants
to go from the picture to the left so
the left is really I think perhaps an
abstraction of the picture right exactly
so because we have this rule that the
notes and the disciplic notes we're not
going to allow them to change that's
just a design decision then this
relationship between this point of
relationships corresponding to this fun
no directly part of the environment they
are they are fixed they are static in
this case Tom pointed out was that you
can also use most of the steering
audition on the graphical site you can
have more stages on the edges that mr.
Peters I guess I'm trying to that's what
I'm trying to understand and that was
under the impression at first that
you're left encoding is an exacting
calling on information in the pictures
and how you're saying now is just
associated so together this environment
plus the information in the two
scenarios that those two things together
encompass the information on in the
picture so so this is the basic idea you
have the scenarios and what do we do
from this scenario since we actually do
fine a we actually define a predicate
abstraction over our domain of lists and
in this case it's it's something very
simple we have already our sets of nodes
so in this case we and we also have that
every variable in every location in the
every every location in the program
every variable can point to a very
specific set of location so we have that
head could either point to this front
note or some nodes corresponding to
front and or to the null pointer and we
have that next good point to either B or
X or to know so socially what we have is
we have a set of predicates that define
an abstract domain and and so from those
predicates
what we do is we construct an abstract
domain in this case each valuation of
the predicates corresponds to a
particular set of states and what we
have is essentially this power set
domain where you you can represent it as
a bit vector and every bit corresponds
to one of these abstract states which in
turn correspond to valuations of these
predicates and you can actually frame
this entire synthesis problem as a very
as a very simple data flow analysis so
this actually borrowing from from the
work of swore above summit that consume
it that that essentially tells you that
you can actually do synthesis on top of
an abstract on top of predicate
abstraction and in this setting it
actually leads to a very simple
formulation so in this case what you
have is the scaffold or the sketch gives
you the structure of the solution and
what you're trying to figure out or what
dysfunctions f3 + f2 and f 1 and this f
predicate you're trying to figure out
what they are and so what this leads to
is essentially a set of equations that
tells you that there are each one of
these f1 f2 f3 FP and negation of FP
they are actually parameterize they are
actually parameterised by a bit vector
in such a way that depending on the
value of the parameters you're going to
get a different concrete piece of code
for f2 or for of 3 and so what you're
really looking for is that there exists
a value of t1 and t2 and t3 where this
T's correspond to your bit vector
representation of your abstract domain
and this C corresponds to the set of
bits that determine how all of these
unknown piece of codes are going to get
instantiated and because we're doing
predicate obstruction in principle you
can solve this in one shot this is just
a satisfiability problem that that you
can solve with one shot and
an interesting observation is that if
you're only trying to do synthesis and
if you're not really trying to find
invariant you don't actually care to to
find the least fixed point because after
all if you find some values for the
different missing piece of code it works
for any fixed point then it's going to
work for the least fixed point so you
don't really care about minimizing that
is actually very important and the fact
that what this is going to give you is
this is going to give you partial
correctness so and currently we actually
were actually not we actually haven't
gotten to the point of doing more than
partial correctness so what this means
is that this is giving you a set of
constraints such that any solution to
this constraints is going to satisfy
your storyboard potentially it's going
to look forever yes
yeah so actually one of the things that
you have here is that your storyboard
doesn't have to have abstract notes
right so you can also provide a couple
of concrete input-output examples and
and if you have a couple of concrete and
put out for example then this just
becomes a simple inductive a simple
inductive synthesis yeah just a while
and then we call it right today so one
of the things that we do require is that
at the end of the at the end of the
process you have for your final state we
actually require that the system finds a
solution to the data flow equation such
that the final state is identical to
this now sure it could make up some
values out of thin air and then and then
say yeah here here it is it looks like
it works correctly even though it
actually doesn't terminate for any
inputs when you have concrete
input-output pairs though you then it
really becomes like the inductive
synthesis that we do in standard sketch
where we actually require termination
after a fixed number of iterations one
of the things that that we like actually
about this constraints is that they are
compatible with the constraints that we
generate in sketch which means in sketch
you can write for example a test method
and say I want my solution to actually
work correctly for this test method for
all inputs within this bounded size and
I want everything to terminate for those
inputs and you can actually just take
these constraints combine them with the
constraints that you get from sketch and
get and get determination out of that
so so the first question is well does
this work and and the short answer is
yes so we've this are some of the this
are some of the experiments that that
we've run things like inserting into the
linked list it turns out if you want to
delete from a linked list then all you
have to do is swap this this inputs and
outputs in your storyboard and then you
get then you get a storyboard for link
Lee's deletion for free inserting into a
binary search tree is another another
interesting one so you can see that the
space of possible solutions that the
system is considering is quite
astronomical the the performance is not
the performance is not amazing it's of
the order of a few minutes but but it's
it's reasonable but when we started
playing with this yeah that is very
strongly true one of the things we
realized that when we started playing
with this and with just this very simple
formulation was that this formulation is
great for scan and modify type of
manipulations something like inserting
into a list where the solution is of the
form you go to scan through some portion
of the list and then you're going to get
to this middle interesting part we're
actually going to modify it so something
like in turning into a linked list
certainly falls into that pattern
something like removing into a linked
list certainly falls into that pattern
something like inserting into a binary
tree certainly falls into that pattern
but something like reversing a list for
example does not fall into that pattern
yes sorry splay tree also requires a
little bit more than just scan and
modify because also require some
restructuring of the tree similarly in
the case of something like a red black
tree it's so in order to deal with those
kind of manipulations we really need
more than this any question oh
so so dealing with more complex
operations really require additional
machinery and in particular are dealing
with something like linked list reversal
really requires some level of inductive
reasoning which this kind of abstraction
like the one that I showed here doesn't
really support the kind of inductive
reasoning that you need for something
like an in-place linked list reversal
what is this way to do what is it
difference between insert in universal
I'll show you in a second i think this
example will make it very clear so let's
say i want to insert into a linked list
and a reverse a linked list so one way I
can describe it is as follows I'm going
to have this head node a and then it's
going to point to some middle part of
the list and then that is going to point
to some end of the list z and what I
want to get is I want to get essentially
the same thing but but backwards and
here's the thing the way this link list
reversal works is that you essentially
this middle part you actually have to
break it down into two separate pieces
and the way this in place linked list
reversal happens is that you have one
part of the list that you've already
reversed and there's already pointing
backwards you have another part of the
list that is still pointing forward and
essentially you have to keep pointers
pointing to the edges of that gap in the
middle where the list goes from pointing
backwards to pointing forward and what
happens is that every iteration this gap
moves by one step and so in order to
reason about this kind of transformation
you really need to reason about what's
going on in this middle part to a much
greater level of detail than what the
rules that I described earlier allowed
if you remember one of the things that
we said here is that this a struct node
we don't want to let the system go and
modify them we want the system to come
up with solutions don't require
modifying this abstract node and in the
case of this kind of iterate scan and
modifying algorithms that is perfectly
reasonable because then the
that you scan that's the part where you
abstract and then when you get to the
part where you modify that's where all
the detail is and then you work on that
part that has a detail and you get your
scanning and modify with something like
reversing a linked list you can't quite
do that you really need to be doing
modifications in this abstract part of
the list and the way we get away with
this is by providing additional
inductive invariance so in this case
what the programmer has to describe is
the fact that this middle part actually
corresponds to some node and i use a but
it really shouldn't be a it's really
some new node connected to this middle
part or just some individual node in
other words this a way of describing
that this middle part it's really a
sequence of notes a non-empty sequence
of notes so now we are saying something
very specific about how this middle part
looks like we are giving it and this
inductive invariant that the system now
can use to reason about what's going to
happen in the middle of this algorithm
and so how do you deal with this kind of
inductive invariance in the context of
in the context of our abstract
interpretation well the important part
happens right here in the body of that
while loop because in the body of that
while loop you need to reason about when
you have to unfold this abstraction or
when you have to fold it back so that
eventually you reach a fixed point and
when you're dealing with the shape
analysis it's actually one of the tricky
aspects of shape analysis the fact that
the shape analysis engine has to figure
out these kind of inductive definitions
of your data structure it has to figure
out when to expand this abstract nodes
and went to collapse them into a single
abstract node in this case on the other
hand because we're doing synthesis
anyway what we're going to do is we're
going to explicitly introduce this fold
and unfold operations as part
the base of operations that the system
hang can come up with just like for this
part just like the system can choose
between doing a puncture assignment or
doing a different pointer assignment it
can also choose just to insert an unfold
operation or a fold operation and so the
idea is that the synthesized program
it's actually going to tell you exactly
where you need to unfold and where you
need to fold in order for the afternoon
interpretation to actually work in order
for you to actually reach a fixed point
and so once you introduce this fold and
unfold operations then the job of the
synthesizer and the abstract
interpretation becomes very very similar
to what we had before the only
difference is that now you have this new
extra operation that when you apply fold
into something that looks like this then
you're going to get something that looks
like this when you apply fall to
something that looks like this you're
going to get something that looks like
this when you apply and fault then it's
non terrific you can either get this or
you can get this and you don't know yes
essentially telling me that you are
going to synthesize
exactly so the code that is synthesized
is going to have explicitly there it's
going to tell you this is where you fold
this is where your fault and you fold on
whatever this pointer is pointing to
movie have a synthetic instruction serve
in our code just a guide check that's
exactly right and you will actually also
have to score okay that's exactly right
because even though they have no runtime
effect from the point of view of making
the abstract interpretation work they
are crucial and any solution that
doesn't have them it's not going to
verify according to the appstore
interpreter so that's the basic idea now
what are the big obstacles in order to
make this work the biggest obstacle is
that when you have something like this
you're absurd domain can start growing
and it's going to start growing quite a
bit so for this example we have
something of the order of seven to the
ninth possible abstract state so what
that means is that your space is now
partitioned into your infinite space of
lists is now partitioned into seven to
the ninth possible states well it's not
that much until you realize that you
actually have a power sub domain it's
true it's it's the fact that in the
previous setting what we had was when we
wanted to do one shot synthesis
essentially what we had is this t1 t2
and t3 have you had one bit right there
for every one of those half start states
so what that means is that now the width
of t1 t2 and t3 has to be seven to the
ninth and having T 1 and 2 283 have a
width of 72 the mind which gives you
then a search space of 2 to the seventh
to the ninth then it doesn't work so
exactly so so how can we deal with this
as this this kind of sounds like like a
showstopper right well it's we have a
trick on your sleeve so so what is this
trick so before when we're doing sky
we have this algorithm for doing
counterexample guided inductive
synthesis and the idea of counterexample
guided inductive synthesis is that you
have automated validation and as part of
these automated validation and and so
what you have is you have this inductive
synthesizer that has some concrete
inputs and based on those concrete
inputs it's going to sound SI something
that works for those concrete inputs and
it doesn't care what else happens in the
world it just cares that for those
inputs it works and so that solution is
thrown down defense to an automated
validation procedure that then goes and
checks whether this is indeed correct or
not and in the case of sketch that was
just a symbolic model checker in the
case of sequential things it was just
spin in the case of concurrent things
but what you wanted to get out of that
with a counterexample input and so by
following this idea of inductive
synthesis the idea is that you never
have to instantiate this problem that
says for all possible inputs instead you
only accentuate it for a small number of
inputs and from that small number of
inputs you get a solution that happens
to generalize it happens to generalize
for all inputs so what do we want to do
is we want to expand this idea in the
context of abstract interpretation now
why is it tricky to expand this in the
context of abstract interpretation well
the problem is if you do after an
interpretation here what you're going to
get out of it is not a what you
virtually and out of it is not a
counterexample input that says oh yes
this counterexample input is where your
concrete solution fails and moreover
because we're doing abstraction we don't
want to do inductive synthesis on a
concrete input and on in the concrete
space we really want to do this in the
abstract setting so how in the world do
we do this how in the world do we
combine this idea of counter example
guided inductive synthesis with the kind
of abstraction based synthesis that
we're doing here and the idea is very
simple for validation we're going to do
this abstract interpretation that's it's
really just a very simple data flow
analysis
this case because of the fact that we
have our explicit fold and unfold
instructions there and so what you have
is you have your photograph and you
start doing data flow analysis and and
what happens is you start iterating over
this loop part until you get a fixed
point and eventually once you reach a
fixed point you find that for this
particular program that you have it's
allowing you to reach a bad output it's
this particular program that you have is
leading to a bad output so you can
actually trace back the chain of
dependencies that led to the ban out but
you can look at this function f 3 for
example is really a function that takes
some improv startseite and produces some
output abstract state and you can look
at what was the input abstract state
that allowed it to produce this bad
output abstract state and then you can
keep going backwards and it's actually
what you get is a formula like this that
says well when you take this abstract
state from the input and you apply this
composition of all the functions
corresponding to essentially this path
that that is shown here what you get is
the output so this is very similar to
the path based synthesis that soir abbr
showed earlier today the main difference
is that in this case we're doing it
we're getting this path by tracking
backwards from the result of abstract
interpretation by tracking backwards
these these dependencies in the in the
abstract interpretation and one of the
things that is interesting is because
we're dealing with after interpretations
this functions f are non deterministic
so or you want to think of them as non
deterministic in the sense that for for
any given input state they can produce
potentially many output states and one
of the things that you want to do when
you convert it into this big composition
of functions is settle fix that non
determinism to the non determinism that
actually caused things to go wrong so
then what this gives you is this gives
you a constraint that
you can then incorporate into the
inductive synthesizer so that the next
solution that is produced by the
inductive synthesizer doesn't fall into
the same problems that the previous
solution came about and this is really
the basic kind of constraint that you're
going to be added there's a couple of
additional constraints that you want to
add for technical reasons things like
the synthesizer come up can come up with
a really bad solution a really bad
solution that after thousands and
thousands of variations it will fail to
reach a fixed point now you know that
for the linked list reversal that is not
the case the fixed point is actually
reached to relatively quickly it's
reached after I think in this case it's
reach after something like four
iterations with this particular
abstraction and so you want to tell the
system look if after three iterations
you haven't found the solution you
haven't converged to a fixed point then
you should not then that's not a good
solution and you actually want to
incorporate a constraint that says
that's not a good solution I need a
different one in a better one and in
this way the idea is to constrain the
system so that it gives you only good
solution so these we're actually in the
process of trying out as many two weeks
and I'll tell you how it works any
questions up to this point
Corporate Services
the counterexample essentially is this
personal examples and exact space
so we got their model which gave all the
oxygen in the specification material
time so maybe you can actually give
another four other other reservations so
this is actually an interesting question
one of the one of the questions that we
want to explore is what happens when you
provide richer things in addition to
this input-output pairs you have for
example you tell the system for example
that in the middle of the loop right
here there is a particular shape that
you don't want to see or there is a
particular shape that you do want to see
that you want a solution to have this
particular shape and we think that that
is going to be particularly relevant
when you're trying to synthesize
something like a red black tree for
example what you really like to say well
here in the middle there is this and
rotate operation and here is the
storyboard for the rotate operation in
addition to the higher-level storyboard
for the complete insertion into a red
black tree for example
so so this is basically the idea of
doing of doing synthesis from this story
boards and again the high-level point
that you want to take out of this is
that this is really a mechanism for
providing the system with your insight
about how a particular data structure
manipulation looks like about what are
the interesting aspects of this data
structure manipulation what are the
aspects that are relevant the system
really has to focus on in order to come
up with a reasonable solution so as we
said before a lot of people don't write
this big or a lot of people don't write
complicated data structures instead
their job is to go in and go into this
massive giant piece of code that's
already sitting there lots of people
have worked on it and now they have to
go and add functionality to it they have
to use this massive framework to build a
new application but not from scratch but
using the functionality that the
framework provides and this kind of
object-oriented frameworks that are very
popular today they have really
revolutionized programming they are very
much designed around flexibility and
extensibility and overall this is a
really good thing it has been a great
way to improve programmer productivity
it facilitates reuse and it's really
easy to write very rich applications
that deliver lots of functionality with
relatively little code but unfortunately
there are also unintended consequences
to the use of this massive large-scale
object-oriented frameworks and it's the
fact that in order to be extensible in
order to be really flexible a lot of the
functionality has to be atomized into
this very small methods into this very
small objects and components and you end
up with this proliferation of classes
and interfaces and you end up with
because a lot of people call ravioli
code where everything has been chopped
into tiny little pieces and in order to
would do anything you have to understand
a dozen interfaces and half a dozen
classes and you go into one method and
trying to understand what it does and
all you see are two method calls and
both of them are virtual so you have no
idea what it's actually going to run
when
call it so I'll show you an example of
this that that we've been playing with
so most of our work in the setting has
been in the context of eclipse and clips
actually makes it really easy to write
your own editors and write your own
tools on top of the framework and one of
the functionalities that you have in a
lot of these editors is that you can
selectively highlight the syntax and
distinguish between different lexical
elements by their color and it turns out
the framework energy makes it really
easy to do this so you can define you
can differentiate between say a comment
and a tag or a string and make them all
come out in different color it's a great
thing to have if you're writing your own
editor and so we want to add this
functionality to our own language you've
actually been playing trying to write an
editor for the sketch language and you
know this is the kind of functionality
that is a must if you're writing a new
editor for a language so let's start
with what the programming knows starting
out you know that you have this text
editor you're building a text editor and
if you go and you look around in Google
a little bit you find that there is this
actually there is actually this token
scanner and there have actually been
studies that look at how people look at
functionality look for functionality in
this massive code basis and one of the
things they do is they guide themselves
by what people in HCI tend to call
smells which are patterns of code things
like lexical clues to tell you this
piece of code probably does what i want
to do based on its name or based on how
it's written and so clearly something
called token scanner sounds like it's
going to do the right thing and if you
look at the documentation you see that
in fact it does the token scanner is the
one that is responsible for telling you
this is comment this is a string this
attack color it accordingly so in the
case of our sched redditor we want to
create a sketch editor and we've created
our own sketch scanner and now the
question is how do we get them to
interact with each other how do we get
the token scanner to be part of the
editor and so well what about just
calling the set token scanner method in
the editor right then we just register
the scanner
and we're done well we wish it turns out
the story is a little bit more
complicated than that it turns out that
in order to actually make this work you
start with the scanner and the first
thing you have to do is you have to
create what is called a damage repair
and any of these people who study the
smells we'd probably flabbergasted at
the fact that this functionality that is
there to help you color code your syntax
as it has to go through a class called
damage repair who in the world would
have known that a damage repair has
actually the purpose of adding this code
to your class so this data I have no
idea why it's called a damage repair but
then what you have to do is you have to
pass your scanner to this damage repair
and then you have to create this
presentation reconciler and give set a
damaged ER and a repairer on your
presentation reconciler and don't ask me
what this represents presentation
reconciler is because i have no idea but
that's what you have to do in order to
get these to work and so then so what
you have is you have actually a link
between the presentation where you can
siler the damage repair or the scanner
and from those you you can now get the
scanner so what actually happens is that
the editor through some chain of
pointers it has a source viewer and the
source viewer has a configuration and
that configuration the editor is
actually going to call this method
called gap presentation reconciler to
get this presentation reconciler so it
means that in order to get the framework
to use your scanner you have to create
your own you have to create your own
configuration and you have to overload
this method called get presentation
reconciler and then when you create the
editor you have to pass your new
configuration and give your new
configuration to the through this method
called set source viewer configuration
so in essence this is the code that you
need to write in order to get your
editor to use the presentation
reconciler so it's very complicated code
it's not just a matter of adding a
little line of code in a method it's
really a matter of knowing that you have
to
overload this configuration class
knowing exactly which method you have to
override knowing that you have to
register the functionality and if you
don't do all of these things then it's
not going to work it's just going to
fail silently and not colored your
syntax so with the technique that I'm
going to show you right now we can
actually synthesize this curtain we can
actually discover for the user that if
you have an editor and you have a
scanner this is the code that you need
to write in order to make it work and
these and so this is really a job for
synthesis there so there are other ways
we could try to do this we could write
documentation and in fact Eclipse has
really good documentation but the kind
of documentation that they have or with
something like Java doc is very
fragmented at the level of classes you
can find what the source you can find
what the scanner doesn't you can find
what the editor does but if you want to
find out how to combine them it's a
little bit trickier in the case of
Eclipse you can actually find tutorials
that do this but doing with this
tutorial doing this with tutorials is a
little bit trickier because if you have
a hundred classes then that means that
if you want to write tutorials for how
every one of these classes interacts
with every other one of those classes
then you would have to end up writing
10,000 tutorials and a lot of times what
really helps is actually going through
these examples that other people have
written going through and figuring out
how other people have used this token
scanners and that's a lot of times
because of all the interaction because
of all the reflection because of all
this interface is it really requires
firing up the debugger and stepping
through putting break points here and
there and stepping until you find
exactly how these things interact and
exactly how they work so synthesis is a
better answer and what you want to do is
essentially for the synthesizer to do
this process for you to do this process
of analyzing the execution of programs
and figuring out how these things
interact so the approach that we're
following is a very data intensive
approach you could say that the data is
where the human insight really comes
from the fact that lots of people have
written editors in Eclipse
it comes itself with lots of editors and
each one of those editors comes with its
own scanner and it also has some editors
that don't have scanners and so people
have already done this before in
different ways in different context but
you can actually record information
about how people have done this before
and the crucial novelty here is that we
actually want to collect this
information not just at the level of the
source code but at the level of the
actual execution we have a database of
Eclipse behaviors that records how
Eclipse actually works when it's fires
up when it runs what it loads different
editors and so the idea is to really
break from this paradigm that says that
if the user has a programming tool this
programming tool have to figure out
things from scratch by running on the
user's machine by having this data
intensive approach you can actually have
a situation where the programming tools
are accessing a remote highly
distributed resource that actually
contains this knowledge and this insight
about how other people have solved this
problem about how this program executes
when it runs and you can use that to
drive the program analysis tools so in
our case the the tool that we have is
based on three observation the first
observation is that if two objects are
going to interact usually a precondition
for this interaction is that there has
to be a reference chain from one to the
other if the editor is to use the
scanner then the editor has to have a
link of a way to get to the scanner
there has to be a link in the heap
between the editor and the scanner so
these this is going to be our crucial
assumption as part of this work and our
goal is to find the piece of code that
actually make this connection happen
this is very important because finding
these connections in the heap is
something that is very difficult to do
statically particularly in something
like eclipse where you have a lot of
reflection where you have very dynamic
behavior but this is something that you
can actually do if you're observing a
database of program executions you can
look at
you can look through the execution and
find those places where this links get
established and then look at the
sequence of actions that led to those
things being established in the context
of a particular execution in the context
of a very specific editor and use that
knowledge to tell the user and to figure
out this is what needs to happen in
order for this connection to happen in
order for the scanner and the editor to
really start talking to each other so
the other important observation is that
it's always very helpful to imitate the
behavior of sibling classes so in the
case of the scanner and this editor lots
of people have written editors lots of
people have added scanners to them so
there there are even some some examples
as part of clips that contain their own
editors and their own their own scanners
so by looking for example of how the XML
editor and the XML scanner talk to each
other you can make inferences about how
your editor and your scanner should talk
to each other and the final observation
is that if we have many of these traces
and if we have information about many of
these interactions over time we can use
similarities and differences between
these operations to look at what is
specific to every particular insistence
and distinguish it from what is general
you can use it to distinguish between
operations that are done by the
framework and that the framework is
going to take care of compared to
operations that are really the
responsibility of the programmer so in
our case we have we have some examples
for example using the XML editor in
different contexts and we have also an
example of another editor doesn't use a
scanner and by combining the information
from from this you can find a things
that are common between the different
uses of the XML editor sometimes the XML
editor is going to get loaded one way
sometimes it's going to be loaded a
different way sometimes it's going to
catch some information so the
initialization is going to look a little
bit different but there's going to be a
layer of behavior that is common because
it is the actual behavior that the
have to write and that actually has to
run every single time you want to
connect the scanner and the editor and
by looking also at editors that don't
use scanners or that use a different
scanner you can distinguish between how
much of that behavior is really specific
versus how much of that behavior is is
general to making this interaction
happen so currently or database is
actually very rudimentary we have we're
essentially tracking method entry and
exit we're tracking heat loads and
stores but a relatively coarse level of
granularity we're also tracking the
class hierarchy one of the things that
we are not tracking or things like
anything that happens inside and Java
classes things like Java dot util
containers all of that we are
abstracting away we are and so a lot of
the actor expensive behavior which which
happens inside containers for example we
don't have to try because all we care
about is that there is some container
that it has pointers to some particular
set of elements so a lot of these events
are ignored in the database the database
also contains some periodic heap
snapshots to allow us to run these
queries where we go through the
snapshots and we look for connections
between different kinds of objects and
we look for objects we look for the
objects that we're interested in and we
look for where they are connected so
that we can trackback find the place
where the connections between these
objects first appear it's a lot of data
and thought it's manageable and notice
the fact that currently we're we're
again not doing anything very
sophisticated one of the areas that
we're really interested is how we can
use abstraction at the level of this
data to deal with the fact that there's
a lot of redundancy in this data a lot
of things happen over and over again
there's a lot of redundancy across
different executions then there's a lot
of redundancy even within executions so
currently with the way we're tracking
day
we're getting about between three and
seven megabytes per second of real-time
execution yes can you compare this
approach with how gentle or remaining
put he'll work held in this case in the
work on specification mining which tries
to compute you know relationships
between different API calls so there's
an excellent question so the big
obstacle to something like john lumic
mining is that this is not a jungle oyed
John Lloyd mining helps you find this
instances where you're an object of type
A and you want by some chain of course
to get out of it an object of type B in
this case it's and so what jungle and
minding is going to give you is it's
going to give you this sequence of calls
that are going to return an object of
type B from an object of type A in this
case what you want is something that
requires a much richer knowledge about
the runtime behavior of the program you
actually want to discover there's
there's three things that you need to
discover first is classes that the user
needs to overwrite in order to get the
desired behavior methods within those
classes that the user needs to overwrite
and methods that need to be called
within those methods to actually get the
desired behavior so something like this
is much much more it's much richer than
than what the jungle Lloyd provides and
that's why you need much richer semantic
information about the program than the
kind of tight level information that the
jungle it uses the big difference with a
code mining is that in this case we're
using the wrong time information and
it's not just one type of information
about one execution really putting
together the runtime information about
many different executions and the thing
that we get from the runtime information
are these relationships this heap level
relationships that are very difficult to
extract directly from the code yes of
the synthesis you always need a
component that validates
result is actually working so what is
your validation in this case you have
been users seeing the caller appear in
the professor earth yes so a bit point
the validation is essentially for the
user to take the code put it in the
program run it and see if it works this
is actually a very good question data is
a great way to learn about the common
case to learn about how people usually
go about doing things it's a very bad
way of trying to find bugs for example
or trying to find you know that's rare
corner case that nobody thought about
and that is going to get the program to
crash so in this case the synthesis is
really there to tell you this is how
people usually do this this is the
accepted way of getting this
functionality to work and it might be
that for that accepted it might be that
there's there's this extra thing that
you need to do in order for it not to
crash or it might be there is this rare
input that is going to cause it not to
work but here what we're trying to do is
get you a foot in the door to allow you
to get that crucial first running
version where you can actually even get
hold of how this functionality is put
together what are the classes involved
what do I need to override what do we
need to write in order to have any
chance of this work at all
you
and again one of the things that is
crucial here is the issue of insight in
this case there's actually very little
inside that comes from the programmer
who is asking the questions at this
point the programmer has just a very
tenuous grasp of exactly how this
functionality is supposed to work and
what needs to be done the inside is
really coming from all of these other
polymers that have written test cases
for this that have written unit tests
and from those test cases from those
unit tests from those other instances
where this has been used is that you
build the database and from the database
that's where the knowledge and the
insight is really coming from more than
from the programmer who is doing the
programming right then and there and but
still there is a crucial aspect of
usability in that the purdah needs to be
able to provide at least this tenuous
inside and the tenuous description of
well this is roughly what I'm trying to
do I'm trying to get this to classes to
talk to each other and to interact with
each other so I'm going to finish this
talking very briefly about this this
final project dealing with specification
based hardening where what we're trying
to do the basic idea is that in many
cases people right imperative programs
or even functional programs we where
you're a very prescriptive programming
model that says you have to do this and
you have to do this and then you have to
do this and they do it really for
performance reasons they they know what
the algorithm is they want to implement
they know how that algorithm it looks
like and then you're going to program it
but a lot of times where you have our
corner cases corner cases where you have
to do something a little bit different
where something has to where the user
didn't enter the right information where
the permissions don't quite match and
you need to do something different and
there what you have is all of these
corner cases that a lot of times you
might end up having to write even more
code than you have to write for the
common case even though most of the
effort most of the runtime time is
actually going to be spent in the common
case at the other extreme you can you
have declarative programming where you
can
really specify things are much higher
level of abstraction where you don't
have to worry so much about all of these
different corner cases but the catch is
that you don't have as much control over
exactly how the competition happens you
don't have as much of control as to
exactly what algorithm should use
exactly how the competition should
proceed so what we really want to do is
to allow the programmer to write
imperative code for the common case and
then to for a moment stop worrying about
this corner cases and instead provide a
declarative specification for this
corner cases a declarative specification
to test globally this is how the program
should behave this is how things should
happen when you've run the program and
what you want to do is you want as your
running when you encounter this corner
cases you want to switch from these just
concrete a mode of execution where the
program is just running to a mode of
execution where you're really going to
an Oracle and asking an Oracle what
should I do now what should the answer
be what should this value B and this way
you use the declarative specification to
deal with this corner cases while most
of the effort and most of the
computation is taken care of through the
standard imperative computation so the
idea is that as the program is running
it runs into this exceptional case where
it falls back on the specification and
ask the specification what should happen
here what is it that I should do and
there's some amount of symbolic
programming and then after a while that
symbolic state gets flushed out and the
program continues doing its own standard
its own standard computation so we've we
tried this idea in a very simple context
this context is a context of data
processing application so their
applications where you have a lot of
data and you want to write a very simple
program on top of these so here's
your program you want to get the stable
of census data you want to filter based
on the marriage status and then you want
to average so it's a two line program
how much simpler can things get but what
happens if maybe the spouses can be
missing well one of the things that you
know is that you can take advantage of
the fact that spouses the Styles
relationship is asymmetric it's done
it's all right well so so I think good
we can we can conclude and the
conclusion is this a case study for a
much richer programming paradigm where
we want to be able to deal with some
aspects of the computation in an
imperative manner and with some aspects
of the computation in a constraint-based
manner and we want to use non
determinism in the programming model to
connect the two to tell the system this
is where you can use this is where you
should use the declarative model this is
where you should use the imperative
model and we're studying right now some
applications beyond data processing to
security and privacy so so that's
probably it we can I guess we can
continue the discussion appetite if if
you want